president trump taking action on
coronavirus relief
bypassing congress after negotiations
failed moments from now
we'll hear directly from the president
he's blaming the democrats for not
acting and he's holding a news
conference where he's sure to talk about
his decision to sign executive actions
aimed at providing economic relief to
millions of americans
here's the president they were asking
for
things that just had nothing to do with
what we're talking about
and we've been going through this
routine for a long time
number of weeks and it was time to act
and actually we've been
largely praised we have to get money out
to the people
house speaker nancy pelosi blasting
trump's executive actions as quote
absurdly unconstitutional
and threatening a legal challenge but
the speaker also faced a grilling from
the press over her role
in the failed negotiations watch having
no bill at all
not coming to any agreement wasn't going
to provide any of the things that you
want either you're known as a mass
master negotiator but didn't you mess
this one up clearly
you don't have an understanding of what
is happening here
do you take any of the fact is
stuck i understand you you you know you
want to
get the best possible for people but at
some point
you got to work with the other side
right
all right dagon mcdowell wanted to start
with you just to set the stage for
how important was it for people who were
going to run out of the
extra supplemental benefit how important
is it for them to have this money
and what tell me about those
negotiations because
i don't think people are going to care
where the check comes from
as long as they get their check exactly
i'll just start with
and from personal experience when you
have to bust out the finger
you're losing just a note to nancy
pelosi
the president really found i don't like
executive orders didn't like them under
president obama
don't love them now but the president
really found a sweet spot for what the
economy and
americans need right now they do need
extra money people who can't go back
to work need extra money and
unemployment benefits the 600
went away many argued that was too
generous
it was an incentive for people to stay
at home they were getting more on
unemployment than they would
be back on the job but 400
is a reasonable amount it's higher than
the republicans
proposed there's that and then also
there's a benefit to people
who are at work who've been hustling
through
the pandemic shutdown risking their
health
and also an incentive for people to go
back to work through the payroll tax
deferral
he's got the president has the democrats
in a vice grip either they've got to
give in to some of the republicans
demands on what they want
or they're going to fight the president
on giving people
money people who need that money
i've been a financial journalist for
about a quarter of a century and
in technical terms what we witnessed
over the weekend
were some folks getting their asses
handed to them
i like that technical term indeed greg
this
kind of reminded me of the schumer
shutdown do you remember when
the president trump was able to label
the shutdown as the schumer shutdown
and then basically pin it on the
democrats and they've had to cave
and there's another democrat from our
past who thinks
that the president was just pulling a
stunt take a look
it's a stunt um there's no doubt about
it but it's also
meant to be a big diversion from the
hard work the congress should be engaged
in to provide the kind of relief
uh that tens of millions of americans
need
well greg that's one way to put it how
would you put it i don't know dana first
we have degan swearing and then you
think that's funny and then you have to
run that while people are having dinner
i mean really this is disgusting okay
but politics is a magic show for the
corrupt
right pelosi says hey but we had a bill
and you did nothing yeah but
that coveted relief bill was weighed
with so much pork you could roast it on
a spit
there that was their trick their magic
trick tack on climate
student debt forgiveness and then if you
don't agree oh
you want people to die even though it's
you who you know snuck in that
extra relief for our free eyeglasses for
woodland tree nymphs
um so what we've learned is we need we
need a new streamlining system
for real emergencies and not phony
emergencies because congress
congress can handle fake emergencies but
the real ones where you need money fast
you got to let the president handle that
and then punish those
who attach like bs pork with like a
public spanking i wouldn't go as far as
an actual execution
but i would say a public spanking so if
you say you know i know this is a relief
bill for an earthquake
but what about the new breeding uh site
for i don't know uh
uh snail snail darters then you have to
be publicly spanked
because this is the problem the pandemic
taught us
that you cannot depend on congress in
times of emergency
we can depend on them during a benign
period we can they can do their stupid
speeches and fly to climate summits
no one really cares because that's a
burden we can handle
but right now in a time of destruction
and disease and disorder
we can no longer indulge their pointless
activities
so i say executive action all the way
and then sort it all out
later donna it does seem
kind of hard to imagine that the
democrats would sue
to stop the president's executive
actions when they don't have an
alternative to get money into people's
hands
as quickly as people might need it what
do you think
well here's what i think on may 15th as
you all know the democrats passed the
heroes act and while we can quibble
about the amount
2 trillion 3 trillion we can say it was
pork or beef or
even chicken but what it did contain was
a comprehensive way of looking at the
crisis
at that time mitch mcconnell and the
republicans decided to
drag their feet and say well let's put
it on pause before we spend more money
the democrats understood that july 31st
was going to come
sooner rather than later the republicans
came to the table on july
27th so let's stop trying to figure out
how to
blame someone for sticking up a finger
when the truth is
millions of americans are about to be
evicted millions of americans cannot
make ends meet
and yes the president has signed a piece
of paper he got money from the social
security
he got money from fema to make this
happen
whether they decide to sue or not sue
congress should get back to work
figure out what the final tab should
look like and help the american people
i think everyone could agree with that
lawrence that now i think one of the
things that the president's action did
is force people then back to the end
and to get serious one of the things the
wall street journal said is that when
the
democrats were asking for three plus
trillion dollars that
it wasn't so much as a negotiation as a
stick-up
and that's not really the way that you
come to a compromise but now with the
president having taken this action
could a compromise be possible um
excellent analysis as usual
yes we're at a negotiation table now
because the game is much different you
know my basketball coach used to always
say
basketball is a game of run the score
can change
in the blink of an eye politics
shouldn't be that way
but it is the democrats didn't want to
negotiate as long as it was the
republicans that were going to take the
blame
they kind of painted this picture that
the the republicans didn't care
and it was over 3.4 trillion to
1.5 trillion they weren't being taken
seriously well the president
played the same game of politics by
saying you know what i'll do this
executive order and
you can take me to court but now you
look like the bad guy because
what did you pass because i'm already
doing this what are you going to do
so now you see democrats wanting to be
reasonable
and i'll say this nancy pelosi she did
take
take an l and she has to take the l on
this and then get back to the
negotiation table because right now what
she
promised her her constituents was the
post office funding
the hospitals the state board of the
election and right now she's
gonna get zero of that and so now she
has to get to that table to
get some type of win but again this is a
game of runs
right now they cannot paint it that the
republicans are the bad guy
i do not like executive orders but you
know the president got a win
lawrence i have to tell you i thought
basketball
was a game of baskets and that baseball
was a game of runs
but i could be wrong and i'm probably
wrong
people will tell me on twitter all right